This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. It's everybody's favorite time of year. Girls all over America are spending thousands of dollars at Kendris Scott, Lulu Lemon, and going crazy on Revolve. No, seriously, guys, it is time for sorority rush. You'll learn about the sex lives of sorority girls. Plus, we'll reveal what frat boys really think about sorority girls. Listen to Dirty Rush on America's number one podcast network, IHeart.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。这是每个人一年中最喜欢的时刻。全美各地的女孩们在肯德里斯·斯科特（Kendris Scott）和露露柠檬（Lulu Lemon）花掉数千美元，并在雷沃夫（Revolve）疯狂购物。不，说真的，伙计们，是时候迎来姐妹会纳新了。你将了解到姐妹会女孩的性生活。此外，我们还将揭示兄弟会男生对姐妹会的真实看法。在全美排名第一的播客网络IHeart上收听《肮脏的冲刺》（Dirty Rush）。
Follow Dirty Rush and start listening on the... the free IHeart Radio app today. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Where's my phone? Juliana, maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, because I have questions. And I bet you do too.
关注《肮脏的冲刺》，今天就在免费的IHeart Radio应用程序上开始收听吧……吧。比尔，为什么我的眼睛在抽搐？这是否意味着我处于围绝经期？我的手机在哪里？朱莉安娜，也许我们可以问问真人。是的，因为我有疑问。我敢打赌你也有。
Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms? We do that. And I still need to know why my poop's been green. We've got actual people answering these exact questions. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your podcast.
比如，分房睡正常吗？我们就是这样的。我还是想知道为什么我的便便一直是绿色的。我们有真人来回答这些具体问题。收听《比尔与朱莉安娜播客》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方。
I'm Maria Garcia. You may remember me from my podcast, Anything for Selena or My DiBol. I love pop culture. I think about stuff like, what did Mariah Carey and Luis Miguel's relationship mean? Why was the world so unfair to our girl, Britney Spears? And why do some women yearn for Shakita's black hair to make a comeback?
我是玛丽亚·加西亚。你可能从我的播客《为赛琳娜付出一切》（Anything for Selena）或《我的迪博尔》（My DiBol）中记得我。我热爱流行文化。我会思考诸如：玛丽亚·凯莉和路易斯·米格尔的关系意味着什么？为什么世界对我们的女孩布兰妮·斯皮尔斯如此不公？以及为什么有些女性渴望夏奇拉的黑发卷土重来？
I'm always trying to find the meaning behind pop culture and beyond. And now I'm back to unpack more divas, more drama, more stories from the present and the past that I'm very excited to tell you about. We're going to have fun, we're going to keep it cute, and we're going to figure out what it all means. Listen to Mui Excited with Maria Garcia as part of the My Cultura podcast network available on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Munga Chitigula and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talk to scientists, biopunks, kermudgens, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us.
我一直在寻找流行文化背后的意义及其他。现在我回来了，将为大家剖析更多天后、更多戏剧性事件、更多过去与现在的故事，我非常高兴能与你们分享。我们会玩得很开心，保持可爱，并弄清楚这一切意味着什么。收听由玛丽亚·加西亚主持的《兴奋不已》（Mui Excited），这是My Cultura播客网络的一部分，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听。我是芒加·奇蒂古拉，我的播客《天际线大道》（Skyline Drive）新季回归了。这一次，我采访了科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的人、布鲁斯唱片店老板、资深老年人以及果阿顶尖的冷冻疗法实验室，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷及其对我们所有人的意义。
And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
一路上我也惹上了一些麻烦。我想大概可以从骨骼塑形开始。那没用。为了让它看起来更立体。他们说这有用。我不知道。收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》（Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever），可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方获取。
This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rappaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now.
我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》（the I Am Rappaport Stereo podcast）与你听过的任何节目都不同。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何其他吸引我注意的事情的强烈观点，那么现在就订阅吧。
This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rappaport on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the
这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊的小伙子绝对应该因为饰演迈克尔·杰克逊而获得提名。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听《我是拉帕波特》，无论你在哪里收听播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时遇到的最大改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一集节目，当然我们要剖析的是
psychology of your 20s, my 20s, our 20s. Just a reminder, this episode and all of our other episodes are now on Netflix. So if you are somebody who likes video podcast, this is the place to go for full transparency. This is a new thing for Netflix as well. And we would love for them to hopefully ask us to do another season. So if you haven't checked it out, if it's something that interest you. Our full video episodes are now over there. Now is the time. It really does help me and the podcast out, so I'd really appreciate it. But let's get into the episode. Today, I am bringing you all a classic how-to episode. I do these every now and again for topics that like kind of aren't unified by a singular psychological concept or explanation or theory, but they have so much
你二十岁的心理学、我二十岁的心理学、我们二十岁的心理学。只需提醒一下，本集和我们的所有其他节目现在都在Netflix上播出。所以如果你是一个喜欢视频播客的人，这里就是你的去处。坦白说，这对Netflix来说也是一件新鲜事。我们希望他们能邀请我们再拍一季。所以如果你还没看过，如果你对它感兴趣的话。我们的完整视频节目现在就在那里。现在正是时候。这确实对我和播客很有帮助，所以我真的很感激。但让我们进入本集节目。今天，我为大家带来一个经典的操作指南类节目。我每隔一段时间就会针对一些不被单一心理概念、解释或理论所统领的主题制作这样的节目，但它们包含如此多的
step to them that they deserve their own category of episode. We've done. How to avoid settling in your 20s. How to manage your anxiety about the future. How to do hard things. How to get out of a funk. How to anything. And today, we are doing my favorite so far, a personal topic I cannot shut up about, which is how to be more interesting. There was a very famous journal paper published in the journal Nature last year talking about how in our digital age, people are increasingly bored and increasingly boring. And a consequence of how much time we spend online is that we are all very slowly losing our distinct personalities. Nobody is interesting anymore. Nobody is different. Nobody is special. Maybe you feel that way about yourself, that you're not
步骤，以至于它们值得拥有自己专属的节目类别。我们做过。如何在二十岁时避免将就。如何管理你对未来的焦虑。如何做困难的事情。如何走出低谷。如何做任何事情。而今天，我们要探讨我迄今为止最喜欢的一个话题，一个我滔滔不绝停不下来的个人话题，那就是如何变得更有趣。去年《自然》杂志上发表了一篇非常著名的学术论文，讨论了在我们的数字时代，人们如何变得越来越无聊，也越来越无趣。我们在网上花费了大量时间的一个后果，就是我们都在非常缓慢地失去我们鲜明的个性。没有人再有趣了。没有人与众不同。没有人是特别的。也许你对自己也有这种感觉，觉得你没有
as interesting. Even in your own mind, you aren't entertaining yourself. You aren't entertaining yourself. as much. You're not fascinated by yourself, that maybe you've lost a little bit of dimension to your personhood and your personality. I want to say you are not alone. And today we are going to examine why you are feeling that way, why our current environments, plural, are creating a standardization of thought, interest of personalities, and the very best things you can do, psychologically, socially, neurologically, to become a more interesting person,
那么有趣。甚至在你的脑海里，你也没有在娱乐自己。你没有在娱乐自己。那么多。你不再为自己着迷，也许你的人格和个性已经失去了一点维度。我想说你并不孤单。今天我们将探讨为什么你会有这种感觉，为什么我们当前的环境（复数）正在造成思想、兴趣和个性的标准化，以及你可以采取的最好的心理、社会、神经学方法，让自己成为一个更有趣的人，
someone who people feel inexplicably drawn to and excited by and invested in and also how to become more interesting to yourself as well. It is a big episode without further ado. Let's get into it.
一个让人感到莫名的吸引、兴奋和投入的人，以及如何让自己对自己也变得更有趣。这是一个重要的话题，话不多说。让我们切入正题吧。
So the first question and also I guess the hardest question to answer, What actually makes somebody interesting? What intrigues us psychologically as humans and as people and as a species? The thing is, whether somebody is interesting or not operates on two kind of levels or two planes. The first level is highly subjective and it's based on our own preferences. Somebody talking all day about football might be the most boring thing in the world to you.
那么第一个问题，也是最难回答的问题，究竟是什么让一个人变得有趣？作为人类、作为人和作为物种，什么在心理上吸引着我们？问题在于，一个人是否有趣，取决于两个层面或两个维度的运转。第一层是高度主观的，它基于我们自己的偏好。整天谈论橄榄球对你来说可能是世界上最无聊的事情。
counting rice would be more fun. But it would be endlessly interesting to others. I love talking about sports. But every time I do, I can see that my friends are probably a little bit bored by it. It's not as interesting to them. And it works the other way. Somebody could have the coolest job in the world. But you just can't bring yourself to be interested or to care.
数大米可能会更有趣。但对其他人来说，它会带来无尽的乐趣。我喜欢谈论体育。但每当我这么做时，我都能看出我的朋友们可能对此感到有点无聊。这对他们来说没那么有趣。反过来也一样。一个人可能拥有世界上最酷的工作。但你就是无法让自己产生兴趣或去关心。
Because personally, like, you are not invested in that. You just, your brain doesn't light up in the same way. But there is a difference between. being subjectively interested in someone and someone being objectively interesting as an individual. And people who have that special source, that special something, it transcends everything external. It transcends things like a job. It transcends hobbies, stories, appearance. And it comes from a deeper place, meaning that I guess no matter what they talk about,
因为就个人而言，你并没有投入其中。你只是，你的大脑没有以同样的方式被点亮。但对某人产生主观兴趣，与某人作为一个个体在客观上是有趣的，这两者之间是有区别的。那些拥有这种独特魅力、那种特殊特质的人，超越了一切外在的东西。它超越了诸如工作之类的事物。它超越了爱好、故事、外表。它来自一个更深层次的地方，这意味着我猜无论他们谈论什么，
who they're around, whether they have the most tedious job. in the world or the most interesting. There is, and we all know somebody like this, there is something about them that still draws people in based on their character, based on how they hold themselves. It's like a little bit of their soul is just like on fire. Okay, so what is that factor made up of? What is that objective factor? How do we identify it?
他们身边有什么人，无论他们从事的是世界上最乏味的工作还是最有趣的工作。都有，我们都认识这样的人，他们身上有一种东西，依然能根据他们的性格、根据他们的处事方式吸引人们靠近。这就像他们灵魂的一小部分在熊熊燃烧。好了，那么这个因素是由什么组成的呢？这个客观因素是什么？我们如何识别它？
Firstly, the most interesting people in the world are those who are actually interested in others. They go deep. They have a genuine curiosity about you. They find the world fascinating. In fact, one 2021 study had 1,800 participants talk to each other in pairs. People who were given a list of deeper questions to ask about the other person, the other individual actually found them more interesting as a partner. They came off as more enjoyable to be around. People felt like they wanted to know more about them, purely because of the questions and the depth they were going to with the person they were sitting across from. I think the reason for this is that this kind of behavior is so rare. It's so rare to find somebody who's genuinely interested in other people.
首先，世界上最有趣的人，是那些真正对他人感兴趣的人。他们深入挖掘。他们对你有着真正的好奇心。他们发现世界是如此迷人。事实上，一项2021年的研究让1800名参与者成对交谈。那些拿到一份更深入的问题清单去询问对方的人，实际上发现对方作为一个搭档更有趣。他们给人的感觉是更令人乐于相处。人们觉得想更多地了解他们，纯粹是因为他们所问的问题以及他们与坐在对面的人交流的深度。我认为原因在于这种行为太罕见了。找到一个真正对其他人感兴趣的人是如此罕见。
Also, their questions, their interest in us leaves a bit of a disclosure gap where we're talking more about ourselves, we're sharing more. And so they kind of remained mysterious piquing our interests. crucially, people who are interested in others, I also think they ask questions to understand. They ask questions not just to debate or assert their views, but because they are genuinely curious. And they want to expand their worldview. They ask questions because that is just valuable to them. Whatever answer you give them, they don't care. It's endlessly fascinating because of the way that you've answered it and because it's probably different to the way that they would answer it.
此外，他们的问题、他们对我们的兴趣留出了一种自我暴露的空隙，让我们更多地谈论自己，分享更多。因此他们保持了一种神秘感，激发了我们的兴趣。至关重要的是，对他人感兴趣的人，我也认为他们提问是为了理解。他们提问不仅仅是为了辩论或坚持自己的观点，而是因为他们真的很好奇。他们希望拓宽自己的世界观。他们提问是因为这对他们来说很有价值。无论你给出什么答案，他们都不在乎。由于你回答的方式以及它可能不同于他们的回答方式，这一切都变得无休止地迷人。
And that means that also when they go and have conversations with others, they contribute to a greater and deeper level. There was this guy I used to work with when I worked in consulting, and he would ask these like piercing questions, questions you would never expect to be asked, questions that probably nobody has been asked before in the history of humanity. And I remember, we were like collectively just so fascinated by him because someone who was able to get that information out of people, because you would answer him. You would tell him all the stuff about you. He must have some pretty good stories of his own to tell if he can get that kind of level of intimacy with somebody even just like completely casually. Also, I think the
这意味着当他们与其他人进行对话时，他们也会贡献出更高、更深的水平。我以前在咨询公司工作时，曾和这样一个家伙共事过，他会问一些极其犀利的问题，那些你绝对意想不到会被问到的问题，那些在人类历史上可能从来没有人被问过的问题。我记得，我们集体对这个人感到如此着迷，因为能够从人们口中套出那种信息的人，因为你会回答他。你会把关于你的一切都告诉他。如果他甚至能以完全随性的方式与某人达到那种程度的亲密感，他自己肯定也有一些相当不错的故事可以讲。此外，我认为
reason these people are interesting is because we simply like talking about ourselves. The interested person is interesting because they get us to talk about our favorite topic and we kind of confuse talking with that and enjoying that with enjoying them. They become more interesting. And it also means that they're often very good conversationalists, even if they say very little, and they are great unifiers. Even in a group conversation, someone interesting can almost effortlessly bring everyone out of their shelves if needed. They hear everybody's point of view. It doesn't look like a strain. They create at times this like collective conversational flow state for us to sit in. We are also drawn to people who are not just interested in us, but feel very authentically
这些人之所以有趣，是因为我们单纯地喜欢谈论自己。有趣的人之所以有趣，是因为他们引导我们谈论我们最喜欢的话题，而我们把这种交谈以及享受这种交谈，与享受他们本人混淆了。他们变得更有趣了。这也意味着他们往往是非常出色的对话者，即使他们说的话很少，而且他们是极好的黏合剂。即使在群体对话中，有趣的人几乎也能毫不费力地让每个人走出他们的壳。他们倾听每个人的观点。这看起来毫不费力。他们有时会为我们创造这种集体对话的心流状态，让我们沉浸其中。我们也被这样的人吸引，他们不仅对我们感兴趣，而且感觉非常真实地
themselves. That's the second thing that makes someone interesting. The reason for this is threefold. Firstly, we implicitly believe that for someone to be that secure in themselves, they must have reasons to back it up. There must be some deep personal well that they are drawing from that gives them this dimension and depth and confidence. This makes us very interested in discovering what that is. what are they relying on? Where does their self-esteem come from? And why is it so amazing? Secondly, we find them interesting because our natural levels of curiosity just generally go up when we feel psychologically safe. Being around someone secure is a catalyst for that feeling. The reason for this is that we know that someone who is genuine and authentic and just kind and confident in themselves
做自己。这是让一个人有趣的第二件事。原因有三个。首先，我们潜意识里相信，一个人要对自己如此笃定，他必然有理由来支撑这一点。必然有一些他们正在汲取的深厚个人源泉，赋予了他们这种维度、深度和自信。这让我们对发现那是什么产生了极大的兴趣。他们在依靠什么？他们的自尊从何而来？为什么它如此神奇？其次，我们觉得他们有趣，是因为当我们感到心理安全时，我们的天然好奇心水平通常会上升。身处一个有安全感的人身边，是产生这种感觉的催化剂。原因在于我们知道，一个真实、地道、善良且对自己自信的人，
is a lot less likely to need to discredit or put others down to feel good about themselves. People like us. Therefore, we just can kind of relax. Finally, I think we find authentic people interesting because some small part of us probably wants to be like them. We see their ease. We see their confidence. We see their lack of embarrassment.
为了自我感觉良好，他不太可能需要去贬低或打压别人。这样的人喜欢我们。因此，我们就可以放松下来。最后，我认为我们觉得真实的人有趣，是因为我们内心某个小小的部分可能想成为他们那样的人。我们看到了他们的从容。我们看到了他们的自信。我们看到了他们毫不尴尬的状态。
We see their good stories. We see their depth. And we think, oh my God, how do I get that? I want to be on that level. And this spurs our interest in them almost as like a case study. Like they are a blueprint for how we can become like that and how we can improve ourselves. So interesting people are interested. They're authentic.
我们看到了他们精彩的故事。我们看到了他们的深度。我们心想，天哪，我怎么才能拥有那种特质？我想达到那个水平。这激发了我们对他们的兴趣，就像将他们作为案例研究一样。就像他们是我们如何变得那样以及如何提升自己的蓝图。所以有趣的人是有趣的。他们是真实的。
Another thing that defines interesting people is that they just do stuff. They play outside. They make things. They adventure. They create. They put their creative ideas out there, even if it's not perfect. they go to things alone. They travel alone. I was going to try and find like a more complex term to describe this. And I was like looking in my psychology dictionary and I was like, what's the word for this?
定义有趣之人的另一件事是，他们真的会去做事。他们在户外玩耍。他们制造东西。他们去冒险。他们去创造。他们把自己的创意想法表达出来，即使它并不完美。他们独自去一些地方。他们独自旅行。我本想找一个更复杂的词来描述这一点。我当时在翻看我的心理学词典，心想，这个词叫什么来着？
But really like they just do stuff is the best way I can put it these days. Like they fill their days. They fill their lives. They play the game of life well. They're just an active participant in their lives. The next factor that makes people objectively interesting is that they're not just authentic. they are a little bit different. There's something odd about them. Odd in the positive way. There's something divergent about them, as we would say. Literally like the movie, they're divergent.
但实际上，他们只是在做事，这是我如今能找到的最好的表达方式。就像他们充实自己的日子。他们充实自己的生活。他们把生活这场游戏玩得很好。他们只是自己生活中的积极参与者。让人们在客观上有趣的下一个因素是，他们不仅真实。而且还有点不同。他们身上有一种古怪之处。以积极的方式古怪。用我们的话说，他们身上有一种求异性。简直就像电影里那样，他们是异类。
Like our attraction and our gravitation towards these kind of people is driven particularly by like an instinctual love for novelty. The same kind of person with the same personality doing the same thing, shopping the same places over and over again. It just gets kind of boring after a while. someone who stands apart from that as an outlier gets our brain paying attention because they deviate from an expected pattern that immediately spikes interest neurologically, psychologically, psychologically and especially socially. Now our appreciation for these kinds of individuals
我们对这类人的吸引和倾心，主要是由对新鲜感的天生热爱所驱动的。同一个有着相同个性、做着同样事情、一遍又一遍在相同地方购物的人。一段时间后就会变得有点无聊。作为一个特立独行者而与众不同的人，会让我们的大脑注意到他们，因为他们背离了预期的模式，这会在神经学、心理学、心理学，尤其是社会学层面瞬间激发出兴趣。现在，我们对这类个性的欣赏
tends to increase as we get older. Unfortunately, as children and as teenagers, we're very cruel to divergent thinkers. We're very cruel to divergent or different personality types because at that age, you know, group conformity and group allegiance just feels so important when we're children, when we're kids, when we're trying to fit in. I still think they'd get the final word. I truly believe, truly, the weirdest kids always become the most interesting adults. Always. Because they have formed their identity purely on vibes and purely on natural enjoyment alone rather than external validation. And they probably had to go through some really difficult experiences to get there. Like they get bullied for years, they get excluded, only for people to turn around in their
随着我们年龄的增长而倾向于增加。不幸的是，作为儿童和青少年，我们对求异思维者非常残酷。我们对异类或不同的个性类型非常残酷，因为在这个年纪，你知道，群体的顺从和对群体的忠诚在我们还是孩子、当我们试图融入的时候感觉是如此重要。我依然认为他们会笑到最后。我真的相信，真的，最奇怪的孩子总是能成为最有趣的大多数成年人。总是如此。因为他们的身份纯粹是根据感觉和纯粹的天生乐趣形成的，而不是为了外部的认可。而且他们可能经历了非常困难的经历才走到这一步。就像他们被霸凌多年，被排挤，结果人们在他们
20s and 30s and realize, like, how insanely rare it is to have genuine interest and love for things. And how insanely rare it is to have a truly individual unique personality. They totally get the final word. Honestly, I was a weird kid. I think I'm an interesting adult not toot my own home on. If you were this way, confirm my theory for me. If you were a weird kid, do you think that you are an above average interesting adult? Yes or no?
二十多岁和三十多岁时转过头来才意识到，对事物有真正的兴趣和热爱是多么的罕见。拥有真正独立独特的个性是多么的罕见。他们绝对笑到了最后。老实说，我小时候是个怪小孩。我觉得自己是个有趣的成年人，这不是在自吹自擂。如果你也是这样，请为我的理论证实一下。如果你小时候是个怪小孩，你认为自己是一个高于平均水平的有趣成年人吗？是还是不是？
I think the answer is, yes, I want to run my own experiment. DM me, if this applies to you. To take this a step further, though, because this is anecdotal. Science does back up the fact that being eccentric, being different, can actually have health and lifestyle benefits to beyond just being interesting. There's this man called David Weeks. He's a psychiatrist. He's the author of the book, Eccentrics, A Study of Sanity and Strangeness. He conducted a 10-year study on a thousand people who we would describe as eccentric. These people were, that was, I'm trying to think
我认为答案是，是的，我想进行我自己的实验。如果这适用于你，请给我发私信。不过，为了更进一步，因为这只是个案。科学确实支持这样一个事实：古怪、与众不同，除了有趣之外，实际上还能带来健康和生活方式上的好处。这个人叫大卫·威克斯。他是一名精神病学家。他是《怪人：理智与奇异性的研究》（Eccentrics, A Study of Sanity and Strangeness）一书的作者。他对1000名我们称之为古怪的人进行了长达10年的研究。这些人是，那是，我在试着回想
about some of the people he interviewed. There was like an indigenous man who walked everywhere backwards. There were these two Californian people who believed they could hypnotize frogs, people who are a little bit out there. What he discovered is that his subjects suffered less from mental illnesses, such as depression, than the majority of the population. Fewer than 30% had ever abused drugs or alcohol. He also found that eccentrics visited the doctor 20 times less often than the average person, and on average, they lived longer.
他采访过的一些人。其中有一个土著人，无论走到哪里都是倒着走路的。还有两个加利福尼亚人，他们相信自己可以催眠青蛙，这些人都有点特立独行。他发现，他的受试者受抑郁症等精神疾病的困扰比大多数人口要少。不到30%的人曾滥用药物或酒精。他还发现，古怪的人去看医生的次数比普通人少20倍，而且平均而言，他们寿命更长。
Yeah, they were more interesting. Were they also healthier? He said yes. We have to be careful here, especially things with, like when we say they didn't visit the doctor as much. Another explanation for that could be that these people weren't healthier. They just were more skeptical of, let's say, Western medicine, more skeptical of like the system. They weren't less mentally unwell. They just weren't being diagnosed because of that skepticism. Like we have to search for other explanations here because there are some, but Dr. Weeks attributed these findings, which are impressive, I have to say, regardless of why, to the benefits of nonconformity. He said it's a health, it's a health plus.
是的，他们更有趣。他们也更健康吗？他说会的。这里我们必须小心，特别是对于诸如当我们说他们看医生没那么频繁时。对此的另一种解释可能是，这些人并不是更健康。他们只是对，比方说西方医学更加怀疑，对体制更加怀疑。他们并不是精神上没有不适。他们只是因为这种怀疑而没有被诊断出来。就像我们在这里必须寻找其他解释一样，因为确实存在一些，但威克斯博士将这些令人印象深刻的发现（无论原因如何，我都得这么说）归功于不墨守成规的好处。他说这是一种健康，是一种健康的加分项。
Those who don't repress their inner nature, in the struggle to conform, they suffer less stress. Consequently, they are happier, their immune systems work more efficiently, they suffer less from the psychological pressures and the psychological cost of self-silencing and self-abandonment, meaning they have more fulfilling emotional lives. Therefore, and again, allowing them to be more interesting and expansive as people because their authenticity is nurtured. Whether they do that for others or just for themselves, they probably do it for themselves. It doesn't matter. They're just more interesting. The final thing all interesting people do that's important to know,
那些在融入社会的挣扎中不压抑自己内在天性的人，承受的压力更小。因此，他们更快乐，他们的免疫系统工作更有效率，他们受到的心理压力以及自我禁言和自我放弃的心理成本更少，这意味着他们拥有更充实的精神生活。因此，由于他们的真实性得到了培育，这再次使他们能够作为人变得更有趣、更广阔。无论他们是为了别人还是仅仅为了自己这样做，他们大概都是为了自己。这并不重要。他们只是更有趣。所有有趣的人都會做的最后一件重要的事情，
is that they energize others. Maybe that's through stories, maybe it's through accomplishments, maybe it's through their passion, their individuality, their self-comfort, it doesn't matter, whatever it is. It is undeniable that interesting people bring a force for life into any room they enter.
就是他们能激发他人。也许是通过故事，也许是通过成就，也许是通过他们的激情、他们的个性、他们的自我舒适感，这都不重要，无论是什么。不可否认的是，有趣的人将一股生命力带入他们进入的任何房间。
They make others, like, want to learn more, want to do better, not through shame, not through comparison, and not through judgment, but through expansion. And I think that is the most crucial element of their character, even if they're not nice people, the way they operate is still a bit of a human experiment. And in this way, they become expanders. This is an idea that I'm stealing from my friend Erophili's substack.
他们让其他人，比如，想要了解更多，想要做得更好，不是通过羞辱，不是通过比较，也不是通过判断，而是通过拓展。我认为这是他们性格中最关键的要素，即使他们不是好人，他们做事的方式仍然有点像人类实验。通过这种方式，他们成为了拓展者。这个想法我是从我的朋友埃罗菲莉的Substack抄来的。
It's called Crystal Clear, this thing that she talks about is expanders. And she says, we all need at least three people in our lives who expand our sense of what's possible, simply through the way they live. And she was basically asking me, you know, who my three people were? Like, who are the three people that expand me? And this is so crucial because without these individuals in your life, the limits that you place on yourself are going to naturally be lower because the example hasn't been set. You cannot dream bigger than what you see in some ways. And it's sometimes hard to be around people who are more accomplished than us because our ego is naturally very self-protective. Our ego is very
它叫晶莹剔透（Crystal Clear），她谈论的这个东西就是拓展者。她说，我们的生活中都至少需要三个人，他们仅仅通过生活的方式就拓展了我们对可能性的感知。她基本上是在问我，你知道，我的三个人是谁吗？就像，拓展我的那三个人是谁？这至关重要，因为如果你的生活中没有这些个人，你为自己设定的界限自然会更低，因为还没有树立这样的榜样。在某些方面，你的梦想不可能超越你所见。有时候很难和比我们更有成就的人在一起，因为我们的自我天生具有很强的自我保护意识。我们的自我非常
cautious of situations that could lessen our self-esteem. But the outcome of being around expanders, being around interesting people, is a greater sense of what is possible within our own lives, a greater confidence that we can achieve what we want. And that's, and it's called what's special about these kinds of people. So the next big question is, if this is what makes somebody interesting, why are interesting people becoming harder to find? Why are we all becoming more boring? Like that nature article, kind of accused us of becoming.
对那些可能降低我们自尊的情境保持警惕。但与拓展者为伍、与有趣的人为伍的结果是，我们对生活中可能发生的事情有了更强的感知，对我们能够实现想要的东西有了更大的自信。这就是这类人的特殊之处。所以下一个重大问题是，如果这就是让一个人有趣的原因，为什么有趣的人变得越来越难找了？为什么我们都变得越来越无聊了？就像那篇《自然》杂志的文章，有点指责我们变得无聊一样。
We're going to talk about that, break down the three critical factors that are maybe making you boring, definitely making me boring, after this short break. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in?
稍事休息后，我们将讨论这个问题，剖析那三个可能让你觉得无聊、也绝对让我觉得无聊的关键因素。你已经听过了混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接开始吗？
Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish. Right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas, and Las Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there.
从头到尾观看你所有喜爱的播客。就在免费的IHard Radio应用程序内。制造点动静。噢耶！在《闺蜜听我说》（Bestie Listen）、《嘿，乔纳斯》（Hey Jonas）和《拉斯文化主义者》（Las Culturistas）等节目中捕捉每一次笑声和白眼。现在有完整视频了。我就把这个放在这儿。
It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHR radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. We've all been there. We've had seasons that have shaken everything. The question is, What remains when the shaking stops?
还是熟悉的嘉宾和熟悉的默契，所有你错过的爆笑时刻，就在你的屏幕上呈现。打开免费的IHR电台应用程序。搜索视频播客并点击观看。我们都经历过这一切。我们都经历过动摇一切的时期。问题是，当动摇停止时，剩下的是什么？
Hi, I'm Gary Valenciano. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary Vee, I sit down with amazing personalities and we talk about the seasons that nearly broke them, the lows that carried them to their highs. Listen to Unshaken with Gary Vee on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I am talking to a felon right now with face tattoos,
嗨，我是加里·瓦伦西亚诺。在我的播客节目《加里·威的不动摇》（Unshaken with Gary Vee）中，我与优秀的各界名流坐在一起，我们谈论那些几乎将他们击垮的时期，以及带他们走向巅峰的低谷。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《加里·威的不动守心》。我正在和一个面部有纹身的重罪犯交谈，
and I cannot decide if I like him or not. That was a caller from my podcast, Therapy Gecko, where I speak with anonymous callers about their problems, relationships, and anything else in the depths of their mind. It all happens on my show, Therapy Gecko, where we have real conversations just like this. Sometimes I'll have my girlfriend preach to it, spicy food, and kind of baby bird it into my mouth.
我无法决定我是否喜欢他。那是来自我的播客《治疗壁虎》（Therapy Gecko）的一位听众来电，我在节目中与匿名听众交流他们的烦恼、人际关系以及他们内心深处的任何其他事情。这一切都发生在我的节目《治疗壁虎》中，我们就在这里进行像这样的真实对话。有时我会让我的女友把它宣讲出来，配上辛辣的食物，然后像喂小鸟一样把它喂进我嘴里。
Is that weird? This week is Human Connection Week. We're taking a peek into the lives of various strangers who found my phone number online. We'll hear their funny moments, their difficult ones, and their unexpectedly profound ones. These are real conversations with real people figuring out life one call at a time. So if you're trying to get out of your own head and into someone else's, this is the podcast for you. Listen to Therapy Gecko on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea.
这很奇怪吗？本周是人类连接周。我们正在窥探那些在网上找到我电话号码的各种陌生人的生活。我们将听到他们搞笑的时刻、艰难的时刻，以及意想不到的深刻时刻。这些都是与真实的人进行的真实对话，他们一次一通电话地摸索着生活。所以，如果你正试图跳出自己的思维局限，走进别人的内心，这就是适合你的播客。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《治疗壁虎》。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒。
This season, we've got some awesome guests ready to dole out advice. Guests like Tiffany Haddish. Kind of slide into people's DMs. I like Bumble. Also, girl, farmers only.com. At state sales, funerals, auctions are usually good. There's a lot of good men there. Grocery stores near gyms.
这个赛季，我们有一些很棒的嘉宾准备提供建议。像蒂凡尼·哈迪什这样的嘉宾。有点滑进人们的私信里。我喜欢Bumble。还有，女孩们，farmers only.com。在旧货出售、葬礼、拍卖会上通常都不错。那里有很多好男人。健身房附近的杂货店。
Darcy Cardin. I remember being like, I know this is good advice, but like I really don't want to do that. So you didn't take her advice? I didn't take her advice. Are you still friends with that woman? No. She actually was kind of toxic. Neil deGrasse Tyson
达西·卡顿。我记得当时觉得，我知道这是个好建议，但老实所以你没有听从她的建议？我没有听从她的建议。你还和那个女人做朋友吗？没有。她其实有点毒。尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森
I spent my whole life looking up I was a geek kid I had a telescope at age 12 and so... So you didn't have sex for a long time Sherry O'Terry Were you a soap opera person? Young and restless Okay well first of all you should know
我花了一生时间仰望星空，我曾是个极客小孩，12岁时就有一个望远镜，所以……所以你很长时间没有做爱了。雪莉·奥特里你曾经是个肥皂剧迷吗？《年轻与躁动》好吧，首先，你应该知道
it's the young and the restless I can't even believe you're mispronancing the title Some of us abbreviated because we've been so loyal for so many years T.S. Madison Are you into Polly? No, no I don't think so. No I could have told you
那是《年轻的骚动》，我简直不敢相信你把名字念错了。我们中的一些人把它简写了，因为我们这么多年来一直非常忠诚。T.S.麦迪逊你喜欢多元之爱吗？不，不，我不这么认为。不，我可以告诉你
No on that. Girl, why do you not? It's a polly. Just based on what she's wearing and the way her hair is styled. She is not in a polly. Girl try polly. Anna Ferris, Dave Franco, Madeline Kline, Hannah Gadsby,
对那个说不。女孩，你为什么不呢？这是一种多元之爱。仅根据她穿的衣服和发型。她不是多元之爱。女孩，试试多元之爱吧。安娜·法瑞丝、戴夫·弗兰科、麦肯娜·格瑞丝、汉娜·盖茨比、
Adam Scott, Wanda Sykes, and more. Listen to Dear Chelsea on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You said to me, Yo, you know, keep at it. Because you let me rap for you. It was magical. for all of us.
亚当·斯科特、旺达·赛克丝等等。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《亲爱的切尔西》。你对我说，嘿，你知道的，坚持下去。因为你让我为你即兴说唱。那真是太神奇了。对我们所有人来说。
They were like, we made it, we made it. Yeah, I'm like, we? You know, I'm like, I know these guys, but who are you? I'm MC Jen, and this is laugh but not least. I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times, like the co-founder of Rough Riders, Darren D. Dean. Talking about as a kid, do you remember that we met even way before that?
他们当时想，我们成功了，我们成功了。是的，我就像，我们？你知道，我的意思是，我认识这些家伙，但你是谁？我是MC詹，这是《不甘落后的笑声》（laugh but not least）。我将与来自各行各业的嘉宾聊聊幽默在面对艰难时期时的力量，比如Rough Riders的联合创始人达伦·D·迪恩。谈到小时候，你还记得我们甚至在那之前很久就见过吗？
Let me think. Did you walk up to the gate? That was me, Dee. That was you? That was me. The day we found out that you and the whole question. crew was at Hit Factory. The mission was to get me to go to the gate, start freestyling, and see if I could get in the studio. I'm rapping. And then suddenly, I hear a voice,
让我想想。你走到大门前了吗？那是我，迪。那是你？那是我。那天我们发现你和整个剧组都在Hit Factory。任务是让我走到大门前，开始即兴说唱，看看我能不能进录音室。我在说唱。然后突然间，我听到一个声音，
hey, open the gate. Let him in. The gate slowly went, come, come, come, come, come. They all, they're watching this, and they watch me walk into there. And that is a moment that I will remember for the rest of my life. Listen, and laugh but not least with MC Jen on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So I have a few explanations for you as to why we're becoming less interesting. But the biggest one is that the environments that we are in allow for less choice, and that is forcing all of us to become quite homogenous, therefore less unique, therefore less interesting. Increasingly, we are all being funneled towards the same things. Trends and viral content, whether you know it or not, they, and I think you do, they are advising us, they are influencing you on what to
嘿，把门打开。让他进来。大门慢慢地发出声音，来，来，来，来，来。他们都在，他们看着这一幕，看着我走进去。那是我会铭记一生的一刻。收听MC詹主持的《不甘落后的笑声》，可在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方获取。所以我有几个解释可以告诉你为什么我们变得不那么有趣了。但最主要的一个原因是，我们所处的环境允许的选择更少了，这迫使我们所有人都变得相当同质化，因此不那么独特，因此不那么有趣。越来越多的人被引导向相同的事物。潮流和病毒式传播的内容，无论你知不知道，它们，我想你知道，它们在建议我们，它们在影响你该
buy, what to enjoy, what movies to watch, what to eat, hello to buy chocolate. So we all kind of end up operating in identical ways and that restricts our ability for divergence. We shop at the same handful of stores because independent stores can't afford to be in business. We stream the same shows because that's what we see other people watching. And that's the things that the studios, you know, the studios only make so many things that they know will be hits now. We listen to the same songs that an algorithm pushes on us, or more likely a label has decided are worth pushing, because the artist is the next big thing. We eat at the same chains because small indie restaurants can't operate. We use the same apps because they're the ones that are functional.
买什么，喜欢什么，看什么电影，吃什么，向买巧克力问好。所以我们最终都以完全相同的方式运作，这限制了我们求异的能力。我们在少数几家商店购物，因为独立商店负担不起开店成本。我们播放相同的节目，因为那是我们看到其他人都在看的节目。而且这些是制片厂制作的东西，你知道，制片厂现在只会制作他们知道会大火的有限内容。我们听着算法向我们推送的相同的歌曲，或者更可能是唱片公司决定值得推广的歌曲，因为这位艺术家是下一个大红大紫的人物。我们在相同的连锁店吃饭，因为小型独立餐厅无法运营。我们使用相同的应用程序，因为它们是功能齐全的那些。
We even start speaking in the same language that we've absorbed from social media that sounds unique, but is not. Brain rot language, I think is what they call it. It's this deep irony that the internet has promised us infinite choice, infinite ideas, personalities, but has reduced our ability for complexity and for originality. There is actually an economic term for this. It's called global homogenization. The psychological way of describing it, though, is like social and behavioral convergence. So basically, as our environments, influences, context, become identical, we all start acting the same, meaning that the idea of niche, things that are different, don't really exist anymore. There was this really amazing BBC article
我们甚至开始使用我们在社交媒体上吸收的相同语言，听起来很独特，但其实不然。我想这就是他们所说的脑残语言。这是一个巨大的讽刺，互联网向我们承诺了无限的选择、无限的想法和个性，却降低了我们处理复杂性和原创性的能力。这其实有一个经济学术语。它被称为全球同质化。然而，描述它的心理学方式是社会和行为趋同。基本上，随着我们的环境、影响、背景变得相同，我们都开始表现得一样，这意味着小众的概念、不同的事物其实已经不复存在了。有一篇非常精彩的BBC文章
written back in 2014 that described this in terms of the expansion of global brands and how brands like Starbucks, McDonald's, like all of those have started eliminating distinct cultures, and the author of this article, his name is Mark Pagel, he used the example of Starbucks. And he talks about how countries used to have their own coffee chains, their own ways of consuming caffeine, cities used to have their own coffee houses and roasters that were unique to them. Towns used to have the independent local joint. Now you go to Tokyo, New York, Sydney, Mexico City, you get the same cappuccino, the same, you know, marcher cherry frappe.
写于2014年，它从全球品牌的扩张角度描述了这一点，以及星巴克、麦当劳等品牌是如何开始消除独特文化的，这篇文章的作者名叫马克·佩吉尔（Mark Pagel），他以星巴克为例。他谈到了各个国家过去如何拥有自己的咖啡连锁店，自己的咖啡因消费方式，城市过去如何拥有独特于它们的咖啡馆和烘焙店。城镇过去都有独立的本地小店。现在你去东京、纽约、新德里、墨西哥城，你得到的都是一样的卡布奇诺，一样的，你知道的，抹茶樱桃星冰乐。
We all become united or shaped by these. these few things that have enough power or have enough money to influence us when we used to have different experiences, the way we drank coffee, the way we ate food, the way we dressed used to be different. The rise of AI has also prompted some people to be even more worried about this, particularly due to something called the standardization of thought. Basically, the more we rely on these tools, which have been programmed in a specific way, coded in a specific way, designed in a specific way to give us a certain answer, use a certain language, use an identical way of forming ideas, rely on specific sources and inputs, all of which are the same for all of us,
我们都被这些东西联合起来或塑造。这几样东西拥有足够的力量或金钱来影响我们，而过去我们有着不同的体验，我们喝咖啡的方式、吃食物的方式、穿衣打扮的方式曾经都是不同的。人工智能的崛起也促使一些人对此更加担忧，特别是由于一种叫做思想标准化的东西。基本上，我们越是依赖这些工具（它们是以特定方式编程的，以特定方式编码的，以特定方式设计的，旨在给我们一个特定的答案，使用特定的语言，使用相同的方式来形成想法，依赖特定的来源和输入，所有这些对我们所有人来说都是一样的），
the more we all start thinking, speaking, communicating, structuring arguments, structuring ideas in identical ways. There was this amazing article I just read from Columbia Business School released last year. It's titled, AI is Making You Boring. So if you want to look it up, please do. And it talks about how A, how dependency on AI is correlated to a reduction in creative and divergent thinking, which we know as a factor that makes somebody interesting. But that B, the more we rely on AI to handle logistical things for us. So even if it's not creative stuff, but we ask it to choose a restaurant, plan our travel itinerary, even get us from like A to B, even to give us advice to help us make decisions.
我们就越开始以相同的方式思考、说话、交流、构建论点、构建想法。我刚读过哥伦比亚商学院去年发布的一篇非常精彩的文章。它的标题是：《人工智能正在让你变得无聊》（AI is Making You Boring）。所以如果你想查阅一下，请务必这样做。它讨论了A，对人工智能的依赖如何与创造性和求异思维的减少呈正相关，我们知道这正是让人有趣的因素；但B，我们越是依赖人工智能来为我们处理后勤事务。所以即使它不是创意方面的东西，但我们要求它选择餐厅、规划我们的旅行行程，甚至帮我们从A点到B点，甚至给我们提供建议来帮我们做决定。
When more we rely on it for that logistical stuff, the more we become like, everybody else because it is giving people the same answers. It is giving you answers based on data, not based on you as an individual. Dr. Matt's and her team, who wrote this article, they examined what happens when people delegate their everyday decisions to AI agents. They studied 110,000 real-world choices made by 1,000 US social media users. They analyzed what people selected when acting on their own compared to what they selected when they were asking an AI agent to choose on their behalf or make a decision based on an AI prompt, the result showed using AI pushed people towards more popular mainstream options. It reduced the distinctiveness of their behavior
当我们更多地依赖它来处理这些后勤事务时，我们就变得越来越像其他人，因为它给人们提供的是相同的答案。它根据数据给你答案，而不是根据作为个体的你。撰写这篇文章的马茨博士（Dr. Matt's）和她的团队研究了人们将日常决策委托给人工智能代理时会发生什么。他们研究了1000名美国社交媒体用户做出的11万个现实生活中的选择。他们分析了人们在自主行动时选择的内容，与他们要求人工智能代理代表他们选择或根据人工智能提示做出决定时选择的内容之间的差异，结果表明，使用人工智能将人们推向了更受欢迎的主流选择。它降低了他们行为的独特性
compared to others. In other words, over-reliance on AI tended to average out human individuality. It just steered everybody towards the most statistically common or widely liked or repeated answer. It's why I am so insistent in my own life that I don't use AI for my decision making. I won't use it to think for me, regardless of how much time saving it is or how much efficiency it gives me. I would rather the friction of having to spend more time on things or the possibility of choosing the wrong restaurant or choosing the wrong place to visit or making a bad, choice, I'd rather that possibility than the certainty and the promise of losing myself and losing my uniqueness to a technology and becoming dependent on something that it's becoming increasingly evident is very cognitively and psychologically damaging. You know, the studies coming out on
相比于其他人。换句话说，过度依赖人工智能往往会抹杀人类的个性。它只是引导每个人走向统计学上最常见、最受欢迎或被重复最多的答案。这就是为什么我在自己的生活中坚持不使用人工智能来做决定。我不会让它替我思考，无论它能节省多少时间或带来多少效率。我宁愿承受花更多时间处理事情的阻力，或者面临选错餐馆、选错参观地点或做出糟糕抉择的可能性，我宁愿承担这种可能性，也不愿接受那种失去自我、失去独特性的确定与承诺，去依赖一项越来越明显会对认知和心理造成严重损害的技术。你知道，相关研究显示出的结果
this are just shocking and it really actually really scares me sometimes, especially when we're talking about being interesting and maintaining individuality. This is a huge threat. How can you be an individual person when every choice is made by a machine that tells everybody else to also make the same choice. Now I've seen some very interesting arguments that have said because of this current technological and cultural climate, individuality is now becoming the status symbol. When everybody is the same, everybody is converging around a norm, good taste becomes increasingly rare and it becomes increasingly interesting. It's also, as some thinkers believe, the most AI-proof skill and asset. genuine individual thought, genuine interest, genuine passion, genuine curiosity cannot be replaced by
这些数据实在太惊人了，有时甚至真的让我感到害怕，尤其是当我们谈论如何变得有趣和保持个性时。这是一个巨大的威胁。当每一个选择都由一个机器替你做出，而这个机器又告诉其他人也做出同样的选择时，你又怎么能成为一个独立的个体呢？现在我看到了一些非常有趣的观点，他们说由于当前的技术和文化氛围，个性现在正成为一种身份的象征。当所有人都千篇一律，所有人都向某种规范趋同的时候，好品味就会变得越来越稀少，也变得越来越有趣。正如某些思想家所认为的那样，这也是最能防范人工智能的技能和资产。真正的独立思考、真正的兴趣、真正的激情、真正的求知欲是无法被
AI. So now more than ever, being interesting isn't just something that helps you socially, isn't just something that maybe makes people more attracted to you or helps you in dating. It's important for you career-wise to be an interesting person and to have a unique identity. However, I will say, I think the final factor I would bring up is just a lot of us becoming less interesting because we are also becoming more time poor as well. That's making it harder for us to pursue the activities, the interests, the hobbies, even the kind of deep thinking that makes us unique. This is also interestingly, I think, what also drives us to rely on our algorithms and to rely on AI as well, because when we just have so little time, they simplify the time we need to
人工智能所取代的。因此，现在比以往任何时候都更需要明白，有趣不仅仅是能帮你进行社交、不仅仅是能让你吸引更多人或对约会有所帮助。对你的职业生涯而言，做一个有趣的人并拥有独特的身份同样至关重要。不过，我认为我要提出的最后一个因素是，我们中的很多人变得越来越无趣，是因为我们也变得越来越缺乏时间。这让我们更难去追求那些能让我们变得独特的活动、兴趣、爱好，甚至是深度思考。有趣的是，我认为这也是驱使我们依赖算法和人工智能的原因，因为当我们时间极其有限时，它们简化了我们需要
spend thinking, which to us feels like something we can, you know, give away to a machine. Without a doubt, like when you have to work really long hours, and then you have to commute on top of that, and then you have to take care of yourself, maybe your children, maybe a pet, maybe, you know, somebody that you perform a caregiving task for, when you have to do all these other things that necessitate healthy living, like exercising, making home-cooked meals, socializing, sleeping, and then you're meant to have a personality. on top of that, like, it is hard. It's difficult. You only have 24 hours. So I don't want the focus of this episode to be like, you're not interesting because you're lazy or like, you're not interesting
花时间思考的过程，对我们来说，这似乎成了我们可以交托给机器的事情。毫无疑问，比如当你必须工作很长时间，还要加上通勤时间，然后你还得照顾自己，也许还有你的孩子，也许还有宠物，也许，你知道吗，某个你需要承担照顾责任的人，当你必须做所有这些维持健康生活所必需的其他事情时，比如锻炼、做家务饭菜、社交、睡觉，然后你还要在这些基础之上展现出个性，说实话，这太难了。这真的很不容易。你一天只有24小时。所以我不想把这一集的重点放在“你觉得无趣是因为你懒”或者“你觉得无趣”上。
because you spend too much time using AI or social media. No, no, no, no, it's not the case. Sometimes it is that we are just so tired all the time. And there are so many different things vying for our attention, important things, that being interesting is not a priority. You know, it would be so much easier to be interesting if you had like a mysterious source of income that allowed you to travel all the time or a mysterious source of income that like allows you to take on creative projects on a whim or take a day off to follow your curiosity or spend days like deep diving into something or your thoughts or your ideas. That's just not an option for most of us. That's just not an option. We have to be very clear about that.
因为你花太多时间使用人工智能或社交媒体。不，不，不，不，根本不是这样。有时情况只是我们一直都太累了。有太多不同的事情在争夺我们的注意力，而且都是重要的事情，以至于“有趣”根本排不上号。你知道的，如果你有一个神秘的收入来源，能让你经常去旅行，或者有一个神秘的收入来源，能让你随心所欲地开展创意项目，或者随时请假去追随自己的好奇心，花几天时间深入钻研某件事、你的想法或你的观点，那么要变得有趣得多就会容易。但这对我们大多数人来说根本不是一个选项。这真的不是一个选项。我们必须对这一点有清醒的认识。
So those are the three major factors that are making us feel less interesting. collectively, they all kind of tie into this like branch under capitalism. How do we circumvent that? I know I said that sometimes individual choice doesn't count for much in this, but I do think there are some things that you can do if this is a priority for you. If you do have the time and the space and you do have the desire to be more interesting as a person to others and to yourself. Okay, let me get into my tips, shall I? Firstly, I want you to remember the cardinal rule. that we talked about like at the very beginning, the most interesting people are those who are interested in others first.
所以，以上就是导致我们集体感到乏味的三大主要因素，它们在资本主义框架下其实都归结为同一个分支。我们该如何规避这一点呢？我知道我刚才说过，在这种情况下，个人选择往往无足轻重，但我确实认为，如果这对你来说是一个优先事项，你还是可以做一些事情的。如果你确实拥有时间、空间，并且确实渴望成为一个对自己和他人而言都更有趣的人。好吧，让我来分享一下我的建议，好吗？首先，我想让你记住那个核心原则。我们在最开始时谈到过，最有趣的人往往是那些对他人最感兴趣的人。
And the most direct pathway to showing this interest and embracing this is twofold. Firstly, talk more to strangers. Secondly, learn how to ask better questions. Talk more to strangers because you just expand your worldview about a thousand times every single time you talk to somebody who has a different story to you. the stories you hear, the interactions you have, the perspectives you gain, the side quests you end up going on, like, it puts you more in touch with humanity in general. It makes you more interesting because you just aren't only in your own head. And when you're talking to these people, like,
而展现这种兴趣并拥抱它的最直接途径有两个方面。首先，多和陌生人聊天。其次，学会提出更好的问题。多和陌生人聊天，因为每次你和有着与你不同经历的人交谈时，你的世界观都会扩大上千倍。你听到的故事、你拥有的互动、你获得的视角、你最终踏上的支线任务，所有这些都会让你更深地与整个人类世界建立联系。这会让你变得更有趣，因为你不再仅仅局限于自己的小世界里。而当你和这些人交谈时，
you are doing something that is so crucial if you want to be more interesting, which is not just ruminating and letting your own thoughts be the only kind of like compass for your reality, we become quite boring and uninteresting when we only believe that the thoughts we have could be the correct ones, when we only see our own perspective. Talking to strangers, A, is just fun if you can get used to it. I know it's hard if you're an introvert, but it is fun when you lean into it. B, it's good for you. It's good for you psychologically. It's good for you cognitively to just see the world, even for a second, through the eyes of somebody else, and to take that in as an experience. Now, when you're talking to strangers or even talking to friends or colleagues or family members,
你正在做一件对于想要变得有趣而言至关重要的事情，那就是不再仅仅沉溺于自我反思，不再让自己的想法成为你现实中唯一的指南针。当我们认为只有自己的想法才是正确的、当我们只看得到自己的视角时，我们就会变得相当乏味和无趣。与陌生人交谈，A，如果你能习惯的话，其实非常有趣。我知道如果你是个内向的人会觉得这很难，但当你试着去接受它时，它确实很有趣。B，这对你有好处。从心理学上讲对你有好处。从认知上讲对你有好处，哪怕只是通过别人的眼睛去看世界哪怕一秒钟，并将这种体验吸收进来。现在，当你和陌生人甚至朋友、同事或家人交谈时，
whoever, if you want to do it well, stop making the focus be on you. Most of us implicitly ask questions, searching for a specific response, searching for a specific answer. We ask specific questions to direct a conversation in our favor, maybe even back to us without realizing it. Let's all be honest, we have all asked a question, asked somebody a question, I should say, because we wanted them to ask us the same question back. We can admit that. We've done that before. But good questions are what we call pro-collaborative and pro-narrative building. So they don't just bring about answers. You're not just mining for detail.
无论对方是谁，如果你想把对话做好，就别把焦点放在自己身上。我们大多数人在潜意识里提问时，都是在寻找一个特定的回应，寻找一个特定的答案。我们提出具体的问题是为了把对话引导对我们有利的方向，甚至在不知不觉中把话题引回我们自己身上。说句实话，我们都曾问过别人一个问题，我是说，向别人提问是因为我们希望他们把同样的问题反问给我们。我们大方承认吧。我们以前都做过这种事。但好的问题被称为“亲协作性”和“亲叙事构建性”的问题。所以它们不只是带来答案。你不仅仅是在挖掘细节。
They build on it. And then they build on that. And then they build on that. And they build on that. create a structure, they create a story. They don't just look for, they're not just creating random distinct answers to random distinct questions. You're creating a narrative, you're building something, a web between you and the other person. Generally, asking open-ended questions, often ones that begin with, what, how, why is a great place to start. This is because it just allows people to answer in ways that represent their opinions rather than just state facts about themselves, which is very, very valuable. Then it's about taking their response and genuinely asking yourself, what details about this am I genuinely curious about? It's not about, can I ask a better
它们在此基础上不断延伸。然后在此基础上继续延伸。接着再继续延伸。最终构建出一个结构，编织出一个故事。它们不只是在寻找、不只是在对随机的不同问题给出随机的不同答案。而是在创造一段叙事，你在构建某种东西，在网罗你与对方之间的联系。一般来说，提出开放式问题，通常是以“什么”、“如何”、“为什么”开头的问题，是一个极好的切入点。这是因为这能让人们以代表自己观点的方式进行回答，而不仅仅是陈述关于他们自己的事实，这非常非常有价值。接下来，关键在于认真对待他们的回答，并真心问自己：关于这一点，有哪些细节是我真正好奇的？这并不是在想：我能问出一个更好的
question? What is a question I actually want the answer to? What have I never thought to ask someone who does this thing for work or who lives in this neighborhood or who has that specific hobby or who's visited that country. I call it detail mining. Once you ask a question, right, you've cracked someone open, the stuff below the surface is always going to be better. If someone says they're a teacher, that's your entry point. Don't move on. Ask them like, hey, what's the funniest thing a child has ever said to you? What are the parents like? Like what, what, what's the craziest thing you've ever seen in the lunchboxes. If they work in retail, what's the craziest thing you've seen someone try and shoplift? Don't ask about details. Ask for stories. The other thing to remember
问题吗？而是：到底什么才是我真正想要知道答案的问题？对于那些从事这种工作、住在这种街区、有那种特定爱好或去过那个国家的人，有什么是我从没想过去问的？我称之为“细节挖掘”。一旦你提出了问题，对吧，你就像是敲开了某个人心扉的硬壳，表面之下的内容总是会更加精彩。如果有人说他们是一名老师，这就是你的切入点。不要急着跳过。问问他们，比如：“嘿，小孩子对你说过最搞笑的话是什么？”家长们都是什么样的？比如，你在饭盒里见过最疯狂的东西是什么？如果他们从事零售业，你见过的最疯狂的偷窃行为是什么？不要只问普通细节。要追问故事。另一件需要记住的事情
about being a good conversation list and a person who was curious about other people generally, like just curious, like really wants to know and invites people in with that curiosity, is that you have two ears and one mouth. Use them accordingly. It's like a very ancient proverb. two ears, one mouth, use them accordingly. There is this a professor, Dr. Guy Ichkatov, I think is his name, and he's been studying listening for well over a decade. Literally, his expertise is on listening. And one of his main insights is that you can tell if a conversation is good or not, not by what people are talking about, not by who's talking, not by how much people are speaking, but by looking at the listening patterns instead. Counterintuitive, right? But the more listening,
关于如何成为一个优秀的对话者，以及一个普遍对他人充满好奇的人——那种真正的、发自内心地想要了解并用这种好奇心去吸引他人的人，那就是你长了两只耳朵却只有一张嘴。请相应地使用它们。这就好比是一句古老的谚语：两只耳朵，一张嘴，照着去做就行了。有一位教授，我想他的名字叫盖伊·伊奇卡托夫（Dr. Guy Ichkatov）博士，他研究倾听已经有十多年了。字面意义上讲，他的专业领域就是倾听。他最重要的见解之一是：你其实可以通过观察倾听模式，而不是通过人们在谈论什么、谁在说话、或者大家说了多少话，来判断一场对话究竟好不好。这听起来有点反直觉，对吧？但倾听得越多，
the better. We think that good conversations have a lot of flow. No, the better people rate the conversation. The higher, like people rate conversations higher and better when they are, when more listening is involved, because it facilitates more introspection, facilitates more self-disclosure, facilitates more vulnerability. And there's actually normally a through line in the conversation. He also says that in reality, the listener, you the listener, is often the one who sets the tone of the conversation by using back channel behaviors, which are verbal and non-verbal cues, physical, non-physical cues that affect the conversation on an unconscious level. There you go. You are in charge if you are the listener. Also, by being a listener, again, you become more interesting because
效果就越好。我们总以为好的对话应该有很多流畅的来回。其实不然，当对话中涉及更多倾听时，人们对对话的评价会更高、更好，因为倾听能促进更多的内省、促进更多的自我披露、促进更多的脆弱感。而且对话中通常会有一条贯穿始终的主线。他还指出，在现实中，作为倾听者的你，往往是通过运用“附和行为”（back channel behaviors）来为整场对话定下基调的。这些附和行为包括言语和非言语线索、身体的和非身体的线索，它们在潜意识层面上影响着对话的走向。你看。如果你是倾听者，你其实在掌控全局。此外，作为一个倾听者，同样地，你会变得更有趣，因为
you absorb all of these stories and perspectives and tidbits and facts and insights that others just miss because they only want to talk about themselves or they only want to talk about something that they're interested in. You become like a documentarian of everyday life and then you get to bring those stories to future conversations. Okay, I feel like I've labored on that point. If you want to be interesting, be interested, ask good questions. Let's move on from that. The second thing you can do to make yourself more captivating and fascinating to others and just to make your life more interesting to you as well is to choose a niche thing that you love and get really good at it. Even if this niche thing makes you no money, even if it's really weird, even if it's literally
你吸收了所有这些故事、视角、趣闻、事实和洞察，而其他人却往往会错过这些，因为他们只想着谈论自己，或者只想着谈论他们自己感兴趣的事情。你变成了一位日常生活纪录片的制片人，然后你可以把这些故事带到以后的对话中去。好了，我觉得我在这一点上已经说得够多了。如果你想变得有趣，那就对别人感兴趣，提出好问题。让我们把这个话题翻篇吧。第二件你能做的事，能让你对他人更具吸引力和魅力，同时也能让你的生活对你自己而言更有趣，那就是：选择一件你热爱的小众事物，并把它钻研到极致。即使这件小众的事无法为你赚到一分钱，即使它真的很古怪，即使它字面意义上
of no use at all, even if it's uncool, of all the things we've mentioned about interesting people, this is the one I haven't included. And that is, interesting people go deep. They go deep. depth. They value trying. They have layers to them. They have stuff they really care about and they show that through the investment of effort, time, skill, patience, care, even the most boring hobbies in the world. And I'm sorry if, I'm going to say some. I'm sorry if this is your hobby, but like stamp collecting, bird watching, fishing, lock picking. Sorry, if that's your hobbies. But if you
完全没有用处，即使它一点也不酷，在我们之前提到过的关于有趣之人的所有特质中，这是我唯一没有包括的一点。那就是：有趣的人会进行深度探索。他们会深入挖掘。他们追求深度。他们珍视尝试。他们是有层次感的人。他们有真正关心的事物，并通过投入精力、时间、技能、耐心和关怀来展现这一点，哪怕是在世界上最无聊的爱好上也是如此。如果这些刚好是你的爱好，我先道个歉。我要列举一些了。如果这也是你的爱好，我提前说声抱歉，比如集邮、观鸟、钓鱼、开锁。抱歉，如果这些刚好是你的爱好。但如果你
go deep enough, you will find, and I'm sure you can say this is true, you will find something truly fascinating. You will encounter a whole new dictionary of terms, expertise in skill. You will encounter the gossip of these communities. And the more you go deep, I also think the more you enjoy something, because you can, because there's more layers and levels of it for you to push up against. And that contributes, of course, to the growth of your personality, through the growth of a skill. I think a lot of us stay in the shallow end of things, especially in the age of instant gratification and fast dopamine, because it's very easy and we're tired. And if it's not immediately rewarding, if we're not immediately good at it, if we don't immediately find something
深入钻研下去，你就会发现——我敢肯定你也会承认这是真的——你会发现真正迷人的东西。你会接触到一套全新的专业术语和精湛技艺。你会接触到这些圈子里的八卦。而且你挖掘得越深，我也认为你对某件事就会越享受，因为你可以，因为其中有更多的层次和水平供你去探索和挑战。当然，这也会通过技能的增长促进你个性的成长。我认为我们中的很多人都停留在事物的浅表层，尤其是在这个即时满足和快感唾手可得的时代，因为这样非常轻松，而且我们都很累。如果它不能立刻带来回报，如果我们不能立刻擅长它，如果我们不能立刻发现这件事有趣的地方，
interesting about this thing, we abandon it. But if you want, if your priority in listening to this episode is you really want to expand yourself, you have to stay a little bit longer, you have to really, much like in a conversation, like drill, drill, drill deeper into your passions to get to the good stuff. And I will say it doesn't have to be a hobby. It could be a part of history. You know heaps about my friend Holly. We knows a ridiculous amount about Anne Boleyn. We went to Greenwich the other day. I was like, shocked. I was like, this, you're so interesting to me. Obviously, she's my friend, so she's already interesting. But I was like, wow, that's so cool. You can start collecting something, get really obsessed by it. You know, rare copies of a book, badges, trinkets.
我们就会放弃它。但是如果你希望——如果你收听这一集的首要目的是真正想要拓展自我，你就必须多停留一会儿，你必须像在对话中一样，深入、深入、再深入地挖掘你的热情，才能触及那些真正精彩的部分。而且我要说的是，它不一定非得是一个爱好。它可以是历史的一部分。我的朋友霍莉就对安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）知道得巨多。我们前几天去格林尼治时，我简直惊呆了。我说：“天哪，你对我来说太有趣了。”当然，她本来就是我的朋友，所以她本来就很有趣，但当时我心想：“哇，这也太酷了吧。”你可以开始收集某种东西，并对它极度痴迷。比如，珍本图书、徽章、小饰品。
I met a guy the other day who had a collection of 5,000 comic books. And I think I scared him a little bit because I was like, I had so many questions for him. I was like, when did that happen? Where do you store them? What's your favorite one? Because how interesting is that? Like, depth is the secret to a full and interesting and meaningful life. On that, a bonus tip, if you will. You can literally make researching your hobby. I've seen so many people talking about this online. There's one girl in particular, and I'm sorry, I can't remember her name. She's so cool, and she has this notebook of topics that she thinks are interesting, or like people in history, she hears people mention, or like random building. She'll like see a building and be like,
我前几天遇到一个人，他收藏了5000本漫画书。我想我当时可能稍微吓到他了，因为我对他有太多问题了。我问他：“这事是什么时候开始的？你把它们都存在哪儿？你最喜欢哪一本？”因为这多有趣啊！深度，才是通往充实、有趣、有意义的生活的秘诀。说到这里，顺便送大家一个小贴士。你甚至可以把研究你的爱好变成一种日常。我看到网上很多人都在讨论这个。尤其是有一个女孩，很抱歉我记不清她的名字了。她太酷了，她有一个笔记本，上面记录着她觉得有趣的话题，或者是她在别人谈话中听到的历史人物，或者是一些随机的建筑。她看到一栋建筑就会想，
oh, I wonder when that was built. I wonder who that celebrity was married to. I wonder how this thing came to be. And she has this little notebook and when she's bored, so like say she's commuting or she's like at a doctor's office, instead of doom scrolling, which just feels like the natural impulse these days, she'll open her little book and she'll be like, okay, what am I going to research today? And she researches and she gains knowledge and she gains tidbits and she gains facts that other people value. This is a really crucial point of this whole episode. Being interesting requires effort. And it requires, at times, a departure from your norm. If you really want to curate an exciting internal and external life that draws others in, that is magnetic, but also
“哦，不知道这栋建筑是什么时候建的。不知道那个名人和谁结过婚。不知道这个东西是怎么来的。”她有这么个小笔记本，当她无聊的时候，比如在通勤路上或者在诊所等候时，与其漫无目的地疯狂刷手机（这在现在感觉像是人的本能冲动），她会翻开她的小本子，然后对自己说：“好啊，我今天要研究点什么呢？”接着她就开始研究，获取知识，收集趣闻和事实，而这些正是其他人所看重的。这是整集中非常关键的一点。变得有趣需要付出努力。而且有时它需要你跳出常规。如果你真的想精心打造一个能吸引他人、充满磁性、同时也能让自己（这个身处其中的人）感到着迷的内在与外在生活，你就必须放下手机，重新回到生活中去。你必须有意识地做出选择，去追求那些会带来更多阻力，但能带来巨大心理、情感和认知回报的事物、爱好、收藏、研究和兴趣。其实我还想再深入探讨一下这一点，也就是阻力的重要性。但我必须在这里再进行一次简短的中场休息。我保证马上回来。请继续收听。
which fascinates you, the person living it, you have to get off your phone and back into your life. You have to make conscious choices to pursue the thing, the hobby, the collection, the research, the interest that causes a bit more friction, but brings about a lot greater psychological, emotional, and cognitive reward. I want to get into that a little bit more, actually, the importance of friction. But I do have to take one more short break here. So I promise I'll be right back. Stay with us.
我是播客《Encore》的主持人鲁比·卡尔（Ruby Carr）。快来收听我们的全新单集，其中包含大家目前正在热议的剧集中的音乐：宿敌（Heated rivalry）。和我一起深入了解将肖恩（Shane）和埃利亚（Elia）联系在一起的那些歌曲背后的故事。我将为你讲述菲斯（Fice）、《我的月亮，我的男人》（My Moon, My Man）、狼群游行乐队（Wolf Parade）的《我相信任何事》（I'll believe in anything）以及纹身乐队（Tattoos）的《她所说的一切》（all the things she said）背后的故事，以及它们是如何成为这一全球现象的一部分的。在iHeart Radio、Crave或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Encore》。我们都曾经历过那样的时刻。
I'm Ruby Carr, the host of the podcast, Encore. Check out our brand new episodes featuring music from the show that everyone is reheating as we speak. Heated rivalry. Join me as I go behind the songs that brought Shane and Elia together. I'll tell you the stories of Fice, My Moon, My Man, wolf parades, I'll believe in anything, and tattoos all the things she said, and how they all became a part of this global phenomenon. Stream encore on Iheart Radio, crave, or wherever you get your podcasts. We've all been there.
我们都经历过生活彻底动摇的时期。问题是，当风暴停息后，究竟还剩下什么？嗨，我是加里·瓦伦西亚诺（Gary Valenciano）。在我的播客节目《Unshaken with Gary Vee》中，我将与各位杰出的嘉宾坐在一起，畅谈那些差点压垮他们的至暗时刻，以及那些带他们走向人生巅峰的低谷。在iHeart Radio应用上收听《Unshaken with Gary V》
We've had seasons that have shaken everything. The question is, what remains when the shaking stops? Hi, I'm Gary Valenciano. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary Vee, I sit down with amazing personalities and we talk about the seasons that nearly broke them, the lows that carried them to their highs. Listen to Unshaken with Gary V on the IHeart Radio app,
苹果播客，或任何你收听播客的地方。你对我说：“嘿，坚持下去，”因为你让我为你即兴说唱。这对我们所有人来说都是神奇的时刻。我们成功了，我们成功了。是的，我说：“我们？”你知道的，我在想：“我认识这些家伙，但你是谁？”我是MC詹（MC Jen），这是《笑到最后，但不仅如此》（laugh but not least）。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You said to me, yo, you know, keep at it, because you let me rap for you. It was magical for all of us. We made it, we made it. Yeah, I'm like, we? You know, I'm like, I know these guys, but who are you? I'm MC Jen, and this is laugh but not least.
我将与各行各业的嘉宾畅谈幽默在面对艰难困苦时的力量，比如Rough Riders的联合创始人达伦·D·迪恩（Darren D. Dean）。谈到小时候，你还记得我们甚至在那之前很久就见过吗？让我想想。你是走到大门那儿了吗？那是我，迪。那就是我。那天我们发现你和整个团队都在Hit Factory，
I'll be chatting with guests from all walks of life about the power of humor when it comes to facing difficult times, like the co-founder of Rough Riders, Darren D. Dean. Talking about as a kid, do you remember that we met even way before that? Let me think. Did you walk up to the gate? That was me, Dee. That was me. The day we found out that you and the whole crew was at Hit Factory,
任务就是让我走到大门前，开始即兴说唱，看看能不能让我混进录音室。我正在说唱，突然我听到一个声音：“嘿，开门，让他进去。”大门缓缓打开，说：“来，来，来，来，来。”他们所有人都在看着这一幕，看着我走进去，那是我这辈子都会铭记的时刻。快来iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听MC詹的《laugh but not least》。我是《Dear Chelsea》的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。这个季节，我们邀请了一些很棒的嘉宾来为大家出谋划策。像蒂凡尼·哈迪斯（Tiffany Haddish）这样的嘉宾。
the mission was to get me to go to the gate, start freestyling, and see if I could get in the studio. I'm rapping, and then suddenly I hear a voice, hey, open the gate, let him in. The gate slowly went, come, come, come, come, come. They all, they're watching this, and they watch me walk into there, and that is a moment that I will remember for the rest of my life. Listen, and laugh but not least with MC Jen on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. It's Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. This season, we've got some awesome guests ready to dole out advice. Guests like Tiffany Haddish.
有点像悄悄溜进别人的私信里。我喜欢Bumble。还有，姑娘们，FarmersOnly.com。遗产拍卖、葬礼、拍卖会通常都不错。那里有很多好男人。健身房附近的杂货店。达西·卡登（Darcy Cardin）。我记得当时心想：“我知道这是个好建议，但老实说，我真的不想那么做。”
Kind of slide into people's DMs. I like Bumble. Also, girl, Farmers Only.com. Estate sales, funerals, auctions are usually good. There's a lot of good men there. Grocery stores near gyms. Darcy Cardin. I remember being like, I know this is good advice, but like, I really don't want to do that.
所以你没有听从她的建议？我没有听从她的建议。你现在还和那个女人是朋友吗？不是了。她其实有点像在谈论。我有毒。尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森（Neil deGrasse Tyson）。我这一辈子都在抬头看星星。
So you didn't take her advice? I didn't take her advice. Are you still friends with that woman? No. She actually was kind of talking about. I'm toxic. Neil deGrasse Tyson. I spent my whole life looking up.
我曾经是个极客小孩。我12岁时就有了望远镜。所以……所以你很长时间没有性生活。哦，哈！谢丽·奥特里（Sherry O'Terry）。你是个肥皂剧迷吗？《年轻的骚动》（Young and restless）。好吧。首先，你应该知道它的名字叫《The Young and the Restless》（年轻与骚动）。
I was a geek kid. I had a telescope at age 12. And so... So you didn't have sex for a long time. Oh, ha! Sherry O'Terry. Were you a soap opera person? Young and restless. Okay. Well, first of all, you should know it's the young and the restless.
我简直不敢相信你连剧名都能念错。我们有些人把它简称为……因为我们太……T.S.麦迪逊（T.S. Madison）。你喜欢开放式关系（Pali）吗？不。不。我不觉得。不。我本来可以告诉你的。不，关于那个。姑娘，你为什么不呢？
I can't even believe you're mispronancing the title. Some of us abbreviated because we've been so... T.S. Madison. Are you into Pali? No. No. I don't think so. No. I could have told you. No, on that. Girl, why do you not?
那是开放式关系。仅仅根据她的穿着和发型来看。她绝对不是在搞开放式关系。姑娘，去试试开放式关系吧。安娜·法瑞丝（Anna Faris）、戴夫·弗兰科（Dave Franco）、麦迪逊·克莱因（Madeline Kline）、汉娜·盖兹比（Hannah Gadsby）、亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott）、旺达·赛克丝（Wanda Sykes）等等。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Dear Chelsea》。我现在正在和一个脸上有纹身的重罪犯说话，而且我现在正在和一个脸上有纹身的重罪犯说话，我无法决定我是喜欢他还是讨厌他。
It's a polly. Just based on what she's wearing and the way her hair is styled. She is not in a polly. Girl, try polly. Anna Ferris, Dave Franco, Madeline Kline, Hannah Gadsby, Adam Scott, Wanda Sykes, and more. Listen to Dear Chelsea on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I am talking to a felon right now with face tattoos, and I am talking to a felon right now with face tattoos, and I cannot decide if I like him or not.
那是来自我的播客《Therapy Gecko》的一位听众打来的电话，我在节目中与匿名听众交流他们的烦恼、人际关系以及他们内心深处的其他一切。这一切都发生在我的节目《Therapy Gecko》中，在这里我们进行着像这样真实的对话。有时我会让我的女友嚼碎辛辣的食物，然后像喂小鸟一样把它喂进我嘴里。这很奇怪吗？
That was a caller from my podcast, Therapy Gecko, where I speak with anonymous callers about their problems, relationships, and anything else in the depths of their mind. It all happens on my show, Therapy Gecko, where we have real conversations just like this. Sometimes I'll have my girlfriend preach to with spicy food and kind of baby bird it into my mouth. Is that weird?
本周是人类连接周（Human Connection Week）。我们将一窥那些在网上找到我电话号码的形形色色的陌生人的生活。我们将听到他们搞笑的时刻、艰难的时刻，以及那些出人意料且意味深长的时刻。这些都是与真实人们进行的真实对话，他们通过一个个电话摸索着生活。所以，如果你正试图跳出自己的思维茧房，走进别人的世界，这就是最适合你的播客。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Therapy Gecko》。正如我们在中场休息前所说的那样，变得有趣——我知道需要记住的事情很多，所以很抱歉——但变得有趣实际上是关于去培养你的外在生活，以反映你的
This week is Human Connection Week. We're taking a peek into the lives of various strangers who found my phone number online. We'll hear their funny moments, their difficult ones, and their unexpectedly profound ones. These are real conversations with real people figuring out life one call at a time. So if you're trying to get out of your own head and into someone else's, this is the podcast for you. Listen to Therapy Gecko on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. As we said before the break, being more interesting, and I know there's a lot of things to keep track of, so I'm sorry, but being more interesting is about cultivating your external life to reflect your
内在兴趣，并真正去追求它们，为你喜欢的事物付出努力。而做到这一点的另一个方法是给自己设定一些需要你付出努力的小挑战。这可以是一个体能挑战，当然，也可以是一个智力挑战。要有目的、有使命感、有奋斗目标，让它变得有趣、好玩甚至古怪。每个月阅读一种特定类型的虚构小说，到年底时读满12本。每天早晨收听一档每日新闻播客。学会辨认当地公园里的每一只鸟、每一棵树、每一朵野花。记住地图上的每一个国家。参观你所在城市的所有博物馆。给自己设定一些项目，它们除了
internal interests and actually pursuing them and putting effort into the things you enjoy. And another way to do that is by setting yourself small challenges that make you work for something. That could be a physical challenge, yes, also an intellectual challenge as well. have a purpose, have a mission, have a goal you're working towards, and make it fun and interesting and weird. Read like one genre of fiction book every single month and at the end of the year have 12. Listen to like a daily news podcast every single morning. Learn how to identify every single bird tree wildflower in your local park. Memorize every country on a map. Visit every museum in your city. Give yourself projects that have
让你成为一个见多识广、能够说出“我做过这件古怪的事，我设定了这个古怪的目标并且完成了它”的人之外，没有显而易见的回报。重点不在于这些特定的追求本身有多么有趣。而在于它们扩展了你随身携带的想法、故事和视角的目录。你不再是一个只会全盘接受算法塞给你的东西的人——别误会，我以前也是这样。但你不再是那种人，而是开始成为一个刻意追求知识、追求自我成长，并且走了一条与其他人不同道路的人。美妙之处在于，这不仅能让你知识更渊博，这些挑战不仅能让你变得更聪明，它们还在智力之外改变了你大脑的工作方式。2011年有一篇
no obvious reward other than becoming somebody who knows things and who can say I did this weird thing. I just set this weird goal and I did it. The point isn't that these specific pursuits are inherently interesting. It's that they expand the catalog of ideas, stories and perspectives that you carry around with you. You stop becoming somebody who simply consumes whatever the algorithm serves up to you, which don't get me wrong. That's me. But you stop being that and you start becoming someone who has pursued knowledge, pursued self-growth deliberately, and in a different vein to everybody else. The beautiful thing is that this doesn't just make you more knowledgeable, these challenges don't just make you smarter, they change the way your brain works beyond intelligence. There was a 2011
发表在《行为大脑研究》（Behavioral Brain Research）上的论文表明，在成年期，成年人的海马体中存在着新一代的神经元。问题是，除非我们让他们参与某种需要付出努力的认知学习体验，否则大部分细胞都会死亡。这被称为神经发生（neurogenesis）。当我们真正让这些细胞参与进来时，我们基本上就能够重塑大脑并形成新的模式。但它也有助于激发更多元化的思维、更有想象力的思维、以及更强烈的自我意识。还记得刚才那个词吗？多元发散，我们一直在提及它。好吧，当谈到我们的智力、我们的创造力、我们的个性时，拥有更强的发散思维能力意味着你能更好地将那些
paper published in behavioral brain research that shows that in adulthood, there is this new generation of neurons that can be found in the adult hippocampus. The thing is, most of these cells will die unless we engage them in some kind of effortful cognitive learning experience. It's called neurogenesis. When we do engage these cells, we basically are able to rewire our brain and form new patterns. But also it helps prompt more divergent thinking, more imaginative thinking, a greater sense of self. Remember that term from before? Divergence, we keep bringing it up. Well, when it comes to our intelligence, when it comes to our creativity, our personality, having a greater ability for divergent thinking means that you are better able to connect ideas
在其他人看来毫无关联的想法联系起来。你能更好地将突发的想法联系起来。你能更好地利用想象力来做到原创。这扩展了作为一个人的你的趣味性，因为你最终会拥有完全不同于其他任何人的认知模式。你不再总是冒出和别人一模一样的想法和观点，而是拥有专属于你自己的、基于其他人并未尝试过的事物所产生的独特想法。我最近在我的Substack上一直在做我自己的智力挑战版本。现在我要厚着脸皮宣传一下了，那就是每个星期，我都挑战自己完整地从头到尾阅读并评审一篇心理学研究，然后用
that to other people would seem unrelated. You're better able to connect spontaneous thoughts. You're better able to use your imagination to be original. This expands how interesting you are as a person because you end up having cognitive patterns that are completely different to everybody else. You end up not just having the same thoughts and ideas all the time and you're not just having the same thoughts and ideas as everybody else, but ones that are unique to you've, based on things that other people aren't trying. I have been doing my own version of an intellectual challenge recently on my substack. I'm going to shamelessly plug it right now, but every single week, I have challenged myself to review one psychology study fully from beginning to end and to
700字或更少的篇幅进行总结。这就是在52周里完成52篇论文，这还不包括我为这个播客已经做过的大量研究。我真的学到了很多。如果说得通的话，我能感觉到我的大脑在以不同的方式思考。如果你愿意，可以跟着一起做。我们会把这些内容发送给大家。所以如果你用电子邮箱注册，你每周都能在收件箱里收到一篇研究。每周一次，如果你想变得更有趣，想拥有更多有趣的想法去思考，或者为对话提供更多素材，这只需要花大约五分钟就能读完，对于这个目标来说，这是一个了不起的资源。但再次强调，正如我所说，它真的改变了我的大脑运作方式。它改变了我带入对话的内容。好了，够了。我不再谈论这个了。
summarize it in 700 words or less. That is 52 papers in 52 weeks, beyond the research I already do for this podcast. And I'm just learning so much. I can feel my brain thinking differently, if that makes sense. You can follow along if you want. We send them out to people. So if you, if you like sign up with your email, you get every single week and you study to your inbox. Once a week, it's like literally takes like five minutes to read if your goal is to become more interesting and to have more interesting things to think about or to contribute to conversations. This is an amazing resource for that. But again, like I said, it's just, it's just changed how my brain operates. It changes what I bring to conversations. That's enough. I'm not going to talk
自我宣传到此为止。让我们进入最后两个建议。其中一个非常符合“干就完了”的主题，那就是：为你的周末做计划。不要只是指望周末自己到来，然后里面自然而然地塞满了各种好玩的事情。学会做那个主动发起计划的朋友。学会做那个查阅你所居住地区正在发生什么活动的朋友，做那个了解各种展览、集市，并且有一份附近好去处、远足路线、啤酒厂、小镇心愿单的人。独自一人去，或者和别人一起去。邀请他们加入你对更有趣生活的探索。
about it anymore. That's enough self-promotion. Let's get into my final two tips. One of which is very much on the theme of just do shit, which is actually plan things for your weekend. Don't just expect the weekend to come and it to be full of lots of fun stuff by accident. Learn to be the friend who initiates plans. Learn to be the friend who looks up what is happening in the area you live in, who knows the exhibitions, the markets, has the bucket list of places, hikes, breweries, towns nearby. Go by yourself or go with other people. Invite them into your quest for a more interesting life.
我经常、反复地谈到成年人拥有一份心愿单的重要性，因为我觉得它们太被低估了。心愿单基本上就像是为你如何度过空闲时间制定计划或方向。它就像是健身计划，只不过是针对你的休闲时间的健身计划。它就像是为你假期制定的健身计划。它会给你一种感觉，比如：“我今天没什么事可做。我要去做这个。我真的要去勾掉这份我想做的事情清单上的某一项。”我和我的朋友们一直在做的一件事——说到邀请别人加入——每隔几周，我们中的一个人就必须为整个团队策划一次出游。我们去国家公园。我们前几天去了里士满。
I speak a lot, a lot, about the importance of having a bucket list as an adult because I think they are so underrated. A bucket list is basically like having a plan or a direction for how you're going to spend your free time. It is like having a gym routine, like, but for your leisure. It is a gym routine for your time off. And it gives you like a sense of like, oh, I don't have anything to do today. I'm going to do this. I'm going to actually like tick something off this list of things I want to do. Something me and my friends, and in terms of talking about inviting people in, something that we've been doing every couple of weeks is that one of us has to basically plan an outing for the rest of the group. We go to National Parks. We went to Richmond the other day.
我们去了格林尼治。就在三天前，我们去了海事博物馆。我们去了一个啤酒节。我们去参加艺术节。至少，这能让你的周一例会上除了“哦，我周末过得挺好”之外，还有别的话可说。再次强调，我想把这一点与前面的观点联系起来。什么样的人才算有趣？他们真实。他们充满激情。他们也深知新奇体验的重要性，以及这种体验塑造你性格、塑造你世界观、以及塑造你对周围世界兴趣的方式。当你对周围世界感兴趣时，这种情绪是具有感染力的。作为回报，人们也会对你产生兴趣。不过，在我的最后一条建议中，我将彻底反驳我之前说过的大部分内容。
We went to Greenwich. Like literally three days ago, we went to the Maritime Museum. We went to a beer festival. We go to art festivals. At the very least, it gives you something to say in your Monday meeting other than just like, yeah, my weekend was fine. Like, yeah. Again, I want to link this back to early points. What makes somebody interesting? They're authentic. They have passion. They also know the importance of novel experiences and the way this shapes your character, the way this shapes your worldview, and the way that it shapes your interest in the world around you. When you are interested in the world around you, it is infectious. People become interested in you in return. For my final piece of advice, though, I'm going to completely contradict a lot of what I've been saying.
我将反驳本集贯穿始终的核心主线之一。我知道我一直在喋喋不休地谈论刚才那个观点——有趣的人对别人感兴趣。你现在懂了。我已经把这个观点讲透了。然而，要想变得更有趣，我们还需要做的另一件事，就是让别人对我们感兴趣，并接受我们有话要说这一事实，接受别人会出于真实、纯粹的原因喜欢我们，
I'm going to contradict one of the major through lines of this episode. I know I've been going on and on about how it just said it. Interesting people are interested in others. You get it by now. I've made the point. Another thing we need to do to be more interesting, though, is to let people be interested in us and to accept that we have something to say, and to accept that people like us for our own authentic, pure reasons
并把我们身上的那些特质展现出来。通常我们预料别人不会对我们感到好奇。他们根本不想多了解我们是谁。他们问问题只是因为职责所在。但心理学表明，这可能会变成一种自我实现的预言。如果我们带着这种心态进入每一种情境：“这里的每个人都比我有意思。”
and to put those parts of us on display. Often we expect that people aren't going to be curious about us. They don't want to know anything more about who we are. They're just asking because they have to. But this is something which psychology has shown can become a self-fulfilling prophecy. If we go into every situation thinking, everybody here is more interesting than me.
“根本没人真正在乎我要说的话。”如果这种心态源于曾经遭受拒绝的创伤，当你走进去并抱着这种态度：“我真的不该来这里。我觉得这些人不会喜欢我的。”可悲的是，他们可能真的不会喜欢你。因为我们在无意识中发出了这样的信号：“离我远点，别跟我说话。”
Nobody really cares about what I have to say. And if this is coming from past wounds of being rejected and you walk in and you have this attitude of like, I really shouldn't be here. I don't think these people are going to like me. The sad thing is is that they probably won't. Because unconsciously we're sending out these signals that are like, leave me alone, don't talk to me.
相反，我们需要把具备良好的社交魅力重新定义为仅仅具备社交勇气。我们真的需要学会接受并解封我们身上那些可能被别人认为“戏太多”、无聊、尴尬或难搞的部分，因为正如心理学再次表明的那样，这与其说取决于我们谈论的内容，不如说取决于我们如何谈论它、我们如何展现自己以及我们对世界的好奇心。基本上，人们能一眼看出我们是否出于真诚。2009年有一项研究探讨了。持续受人喜爱的人身上通常具备哪些特质。在这项研究中，
Instead, we need to reframe having good social charisma as actually just having social courage. We really need to learn to accept unsuppress parts of ourselves that we might think other people are going to find too much or boring or awkward or difficult because, again, psychology shows that it's not so much about what we talk about, but how we talk about it and how we show up and our curiosity about the world. Basically, people can tell when we're coming from a place of authenticity or not. There was a study from 2009 that looked at. into what qualities are present in people who are generally consistently liked. And in this study,
参与者被邀请加入一个社交小组。他们的自我介绍被拍摄了下来，然后对这段介绍进行了评估。三组观察员独立评估了每个个体的真诚热情、自信、真实感和魅力，以及是否喜欢他们。研究发现，热情和开放完全解释了“期待被接受”与“实际被接受”之间的联系。自信、善于社交、情绪甚至积极性。这些因素并没有那么显著。它们之间的相关性没有那么积极。如果你带着真诚的开放态度进入一种情境，并带着一种内在的认知或信念——相信他们会喜欢你，你会变得更有趣。你会更讨人喜欢。他们会喜欢你，因为你是
participants were invited to join a social group. Their introduction was filmed and then that introduction was assessed. Three sets of observers independently rated each of these individuals' genuine sense of warmth, confidence, authenticity, and charisma, and whether or not they liked them. what this study found is that warmth, being open, fully accounted for the link between expecting acceptance and actually receiving it. Confidence, being social, mood, even motivation. Like it didn't, it wasn't as significant. It wasn't correlated as positively. You are more interesting. You are more likable if you enter a situation with genuine openness and with a intrinsic knowledge or belief that they're going to like you. They're going to like you because you're
你自己。他们会喜欢你，因为你身上有某种深邃、有趣且迷人的特质。还有另一项研究，我想是同一项研究的第二轮，他们想要看看：那些真正拥有热情和开放性格的人，会被接纳吗？研究对象是一群异性恋男性，他们基本上被告知将与一位极具吸引力的女性进行互动。其中一些男性被暗示或给出了这位女性会拒绝他们的线索。而另一些则没有。在研究中，那些在潜意识中被灌输了“会被拒绝”预期的男性，他们的行为表现彻底搞砸了。
you like yourself. They're going to like you because there is something about you that is deep and interesting and fascinating. There was another study, I think it was the same study, but a second round that where they wanted to see, like, do people who have genuine warmth and openness, are they accepted? And it was with this group of straight men and they basically were told they're going to interact with this very attractive woman. And some of the men were given like these cues or like these clues that this woman would reject them. And others weren't. and in the study, the men who were subliminally convinced to expect rejection, their behavior was done for.
你喜欢自己。他们会喜欢你，因为你身上有一种深邃、有趣且迷人的特质。还有另一项研究，我想是同一项研究的第二轮，他们想看看，那些真诚热情且开放的人是否会被接受？对象是一群异性恋男性，他们基本上被告知将与一位极具吸引力的女性互动。其中一些男性得到了一些暗示或线索，表明这位女性会拒绝他们。而另一些则没有。在这项研究中，那些在潜意识里被灌输了会遭到拒绝预期的男性，他们的行为彻底搞砸了。
They came off as cold. They came off as not very nice. They weren't liked by the observers. But the men who weren't told that they were at risk of being rejected remained warm, remained open. They were more liked by the observers. It doesn't matter if you think you're going to be rejected or not. You just can't think it.
他们显得冷漠。显得不太友好。观察者们并不喜欢他们。但是那些没有被告知面临被拒绝风险的男性则保持着热情与开放。观察者们更喜欢他们。你是否觉得自己会被拒绝并不重要。你只是不能这么想。
If you expect to be liked by other people, if you go in, believing that, like, people are going to think that I'm interesting. I find myself interesting. Of course, they're going to believe that. If you go and convince that people are going to find you fascinating because you are, because you have something to offer, because you pour into your own internal world and that once more, if they don't, that's fine. That is what creates the more positive self-fulfilling prophecy that makes you more interesting. And this, my friends, this is the core of what we have been talking about all day. Yes, an interesting person has depth. Yes, they have curiosity for others. They have passion. They're a bit different. More often than
如果你期待被别人喜欢，如果你带着这种信念进去，比如，人们会觉得我很有趣。我觉得自己很有趣。他们当然会相信这一点。如果你去说服别人，让他们觉得你令人着迷，因为你确实如此，因为你有所奉献，因为你倾注于自己的内心世界，而且再次强调，如果他们不这么觉得，也没关系。这正是那种能让你变得更有趣的、更积极的自我实现预言。而这，我的朋友们，就是我们一整天在讨论的核心。是的，一个有趣的人是有深度的。是的，他们对他人充满好奇。他们有激情。他们有点不同。通常情况
not, they just don't think too deeply about acceptance from others because they either know it's guaranteed or they know that it's just a bonus. It's a nice thing to have, but they like themselves. They have this entire secret god and this entire inner world that they can return to. They have internal acceptance that frees up more mental space to just do life, to just do things to just be passionate, to be interested. And I think that's really what we're trying to curate. And what a beautiful, easy way to wrap up this episode. The most interesting people in the world don't care if they're interesting. They care if they're enjoying themselves. They care if they're challenging themselves. They care about, like, it's a cliche to say they care about
下，他们只是不会过分在意别人的接受，因为他们要么知道这是理所当然的，要么知道这只是个额外的好处。拥有它是一件美好的事，但他们喜欢自己。他们拥有整个秘密的内心世界，可以随时回到其中。他们拥有内心的接纳，这释放了更多的心智空间去体验生活，去做事情，去充满激情，去保持兴趣。我想这才是我们真正想要打造的。多么美好而轻松的收尾方式啊。世界上最有趣的人根本不在乎自己是否有趣。他们在乎的是自己是否过得开心。他们在乎的是自己是否在挑战自我。他们在乎的是，就像一句陈词滥调说的，他们在乎
having fun. But it's true. That's like the secret to life. They care about getting the most out of their life. And I think that is conclusively, at the end of the day, what you need to focus on. Don't worry so much about, is this person going to like me? Don't worry so much about trying to curate a life or a presence that is, you know, that is likable or that hits on certain factors that you think are going to make people think you're better or worse than you are. The most magnetic thing is that you just like, choose something that you enjoy, choose a collection of things that you enjoy and just like are led by genuine passion for them and go deep. And let that,
开心。但这是真的。这就是生活的秘密。他们在乎的是如何充分利用自己的生活。我认为归根结底，这才是你需要关注的重点。不要太担心这个人会喜欢我吗？不要太担心去塑造一种生活或形象，你知道的，那种讨人喜欢的形象，或者迎合某些你认为会让别人觉得你比实际更好或更糟的因素。最具吸引力的特质是，你只是选择了一些你喜欢的事物，选择了一系列你喜欢的事物，并顺应内心对它们的真正热情，深入探索。让这种，
devotion kind of expand outwards and capture people and be genuinely curious about what expands them and what makes them feel good and what they're passionate about. Like that is really the secret. Took me like 50 minutes to get there. But I hope that it was helpful. I hope that you learned something. I hope that it inspires you to just rethink some of the choices you're making, but also rethink some of the beliefs you have about whether or not you're interesting
奉献精神向外扩展，感染他人，对那些能让他们开阔眼界、感觉良好以及他们热衷的事物保持真正的求知欲——这才是真正的秘密。我花了大约50分钟才讲到这里。但我希望这有所帮助。我希望你学到了一些东西。我希望这能启发你重新思考你所做出的一些选择，同时也重新思考你关于自己是否有趣的一些信念，
because I promise you, you most certainly are. I meet you guys. I meet listeners like yourself and every single one of you is just as interesting as the last. And I'm always endlessly fascinated by how you guys are always doing the coolest stuff and know yourselves much better than you think you do. So yeah, I think this is just a little, probably a reminder. I'm sure you're already doing so much of what we spoke about. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for her contributions to this episode. If you enjoyed it, please check out an episode on Netflix. It really does help us out. I feel like I'm begging, but it's, yeah, it really does help us and we put a lot of effort into it.
因为我向你保证，你绝对是的。我遇见了你们。我遇到了像你们这样的听众，每一个人都和前一个一样有趣。我总是对你们一直在做最酷的事情、而且比你们想象的更了解自己感到无限着迷。所以，是的，我认为这只是一个小小的提醒，我确信你们已经做到了我们所谈论的很多事情。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）对本集节目的贡献。如果你喜欢它，请去Netflix上观看某集节目。这确实对我们有帮助。我觉得我像是在乞求，但确实，这真的对我们有帮助，而且我们为此付出了很多努力。
So it would be great if we could see you over there. You can also follow us on Instagram, confirm that theory I have. If you were a weird kid, are you an interesting adult? Yes or no. Actually, leave a comment down below. Like, if you've made it this file, you're listening on Spotify. If you're not, you can DM me. If you're listening on Spotify, yes or no, do you think you're more interesting as the result of your childhood weirdness?
所以如果我们能在那里见到你，那就太棒了。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们，证实我的那个理论：如果你曾是个怪咖小孩，你长大后会是一个有趣的大年吗？会还是不会。事实上，在下方留个评论吧。就像，如果你读到了这里，并且你在Spotify上收听。如果你没有，你可以私信我。如果你在Spotify上收听，会还是不会，你觉得因为你童年的古怪，你现在变得更有趣了吗？
I definitely think I am. You can follow us on subs. stack. You can do all these things. There's additional research down below. Just go check it out if you so desire. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. It's everybody's favorite time of year. Girls all over America are spending thousands of dollars at Kendra Scott, Lulu Lemon, and going crazy on Revolve. No seriously, guys, it is time for sorority rush. You'll learn about the sex lives of sorority girls. Plus, we'll reveal what frat boys really think about sorority girls. Listen to Dirty Rush on
我绝对觉得自己是。你可以在Substack上关注我们。你可以做所有这些事情。下方还有更多研究资料。如果你愿意，去看看吧。直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温和一点。我们很快就会再聊。这是每个人一年中最喜欢的时刻。全美各地的女孩们都在Kendra Scott和Lulu Lemon花费数千美元，并在Revolve疯狂购物。说真的，伙计们，又到了姐妹会纳新季的时候了。你将了解到姐妹会女孩的性生活。此外，我们还将揭秘兄弟会男生对姐妹会女孩的真实看法。收听Dirty Rush，
America's number one podcast network IHeart. Follow Dirty Rush and start listening on the free IHeart Radio app today. Bill, why is my eye twitching? Does this mean I'm in perimenopause? Where's my phone? Julianna, maybe we can ask an actual human. Yes, because I have questions. And I bet you do too. Like, is it normal to sleep in separate bedrooms? We do that. And I still need to know why my poop's green. We've got actual people answering these exact questions. Listen to Bill and Juliana. The podcast. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you listen to your podcast. I'm Maria Garcia. You may remember me from my podcast, Anything for Selena or My Diebel. I love pop culture. I think about stuff like, what did Mariah Carey and Luis Miguel's relationship mean? Why was the world so unfair to our
锁定美国第一播客网络IHeart。关注Dirty Rush，今天就在免费的IHeart Radio应用上开始收听吧。比尔，为什么我的眼皮在跳？这说明我进入围绝经期了吗？我的手机呢？朱莉安娜，也许我们可以问问真人。是的，因为我有很多问题。我敢打赌你也有。比如，分房睡正常吗？我们就那样。我仍然想知道为什么我的大便呈绿色。我们有真人来回答这些具体问题。收听《比尔与朱莉安娜播客》。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听。我是玛丽亚·加西亚。你可能从我的播客《为赛琳娜做任何事》或《My Diebel》中认识我。我热爱流行文化。我会思考这样的问题：玛丽亚·凯莉和路易斯·米格尔的关系意味着什么？为什么世界对我们的
girl Britney Spears. And why do some women yearn for Shakita's black hair to make a comeback? I'm always trying to find the meaning behind pop culture and beyond. And now I'm back to unpack more divas, more drama, more stories from the present and the past that I'm very excited to tell you about. We're going to have fun, we're going to keep it cute, and we're going to figure out what it all means. Listen to Munga Excited with Maria Garcia as part of the My Cultura Podcast Network, available on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Mangayshatigula and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, curmudgins, blues owners, super seniors,
女孩布兰妮·斯皮尔斯如此不公？为什么有些女性渴望夏奇拉的黑发卷土重来？我一直在寻找流行文化背后的意义及其他。现在我回来了，将揭开更多传奇天后、更多抓马、更多我非常兴奋想讲给你们听的过去与现在的故事。我们会玩得很开心，我们会保持可爱，并且我们要弄清楚这一切意味着什么。收听由玛丽亚·加西亚主持的《Munga Excited》，作为My Cultura播客网络的一部分，可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我是Mangayshatigula，我带着我的播客《天际线大道》的新季回来了。这一次，我与科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的老头、蓝调音乐人、超级老年人、
and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know.
以及果阿顶尖的冷冻疗法实验室进行了交谈，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷以及它对我们所有人的意义。这一路上我也惹上了不少麻烦。我可以说大概从骨骼塑形开始吧。那不管用。为了让轮廓更分明。他们说管用。我不知道。
Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rapaport Stereo podcast is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《天际线大道：如何永生》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《I Am Rapaport立体声播客》与你听过的任何人都不一样。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何引起我注意的事物的强烈观点，那就马上订阅吧。
This kid, Jafar, Jack. should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rap Report on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个叫杰法尔的小家伙、杰克。绝对应该因他扮演迈克尔·杰克逊的表演获得提名。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《I Am Rap Report》。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。